I asked my mum what she thought of it
and she thought it was sweet
ER in for their own intimate
scene horrible that felt super weird the
Netflix hit sex education is very much
about uh well it's in the name filming
these explicit and intimate scenes was
challenging and embarrassing for the
actors but this show made a pioneering
move in the industry that made the
explicit filming much easier to deal
with after days and days of it it's
performed an extensive solo intimacy
scene that saw him struggling to
pleasure himself in the first season
I've never done this much um wanking on
camera as we would expect it was an
awkward experience for the actor to
perform the scene alone but in front of
a whole crew struggling to hit all the
marks the team gave Butterfield a fake
piece of anatomy to use as a prop that
poked through the fly of Butterfield's
pants just when the actor didn't think
it could get more awkward it was the
prop only made things worse so he
ditched the cold and awkward peace and
just continued performing I was quite
open but now I'm ridiculously open about
it Amy Lou wood has plenty of intimate
and intense scenes throughout the series
but for the bafta award-winning actress
the scene she filmed by herself were the
most intimidating her self-pleasuring
scene was extremely nerve-wracking since
she couldn't even joke about it with
another scene partner all eyes were on
her however since there was an intimacy
coordinator on set it made tackling all
these risque moments easier I know
exactly what I want that's uh excellent
shooting had quite the day during his
first week on set that involved a whole
lot of literal bananas rehearsing for
one of the scenes wound up getting messy
I had to get like bananas regurgitated
on me that wasn't the end of working
with the tropical fruit though yanwa
also ended up giving an explicit
tutorial using the banana as a prop talk
about diving in off the deep end
[Music]
hidar William Sterling's embarrassment
came from one of the tools used to help
tackle the more R-rated material a
modesty pouch was used to cover the
men's bits but William Sterling was very
worried by the idea that it could fall
off exposing him completely to everyone
on set to sure everything stayed in
place the actor wrapped the satin pouch
very tightly and taped it to his body
while he felt better doing the scenes
taking it off was another story and when
I took it off it was like
as a central character in the show Otis
actor Asa Butterfield spent a lot of
time getting explicit for the cameras by
himself I get my fair share of
stuff like that you know
for Butterfield performing such a
private act publicly over and over was
very embarrassing and he almost couldn't
believe he was really doing it after
performing the intimate moment so often
though it became Clockwork and he got
used to diving into the awkward scenes
without too much hesitation they will
not do it again I promise it wasn't just
performers who had an awkward time when
it came to working with explicit scenes
the writers were the ones who had to
come up with all the ideas by literally
writing them Creator Laurie Nunn at
first approached the moments with more
flowery language until she realized it
was even more embarrassing none
eventually figured out that the easiest
way to write was by telling it like it
is and writing precisely what was meant
to be seen on screen that's what I
wanted to focus on there was plenty to
think about on set filming these
embarrassing scenes but for Amy Lou wood
there was a lot more to consider than
just performing the actress would worry
about the final product looking fake or
awkward wood and her nude scene co-star
Connor swindles initially rehearsed
fully clothed and the team was able to
confirm that it didn't fact look
realistic so they went through the
motions until they were ready to strip
down and perform for the camera
did you just fake it don't be stupid
Tanya Reynolds really hit the ground
running when she began playing Lily on
sex education her very first scene
proved to be the most embarrassing since
it involved her trying to get intimate
with Eric I was like hi everyone
very shortly after meeting everyone
Reynolds had to strip down and dive
right into the explicit scenes talk
about a fast introduction it can't get
much more embarrassing than that so
after the fact filming any intimate
moments was a bit easier I'm not very
experienced
neither that's the whole point
considering the name of the show it's no
surprise the team Dove right into the
nitty-gritty capturing all the intimate
moments we see throughout the series for
Emma Mackie the pressure was on from the
very first day because it was just
really nerve-wracking the actress had to
dive into some of her more explicit
scenes during the first week while she
was still getting to know everyone
fortunately the crew became so close
that they were comfortable filming
pretty well anything in front of each
other by the end
so
hidar William Sterling's most
embarrassing scene to film shockingly
wasn't one of the sensual ones at all
the actor felt his performance as Romeo
in the strange costume designed by Lily
was the most awkward to film on this
massive like penis shaped stage that was
quite fun it is an embarrassing one just
to watch so we can only imagine how many
laughs there were behind the scenes I
can't complain before the show aired all
the actors had to have some pretty open
discussions with their families about
what to expect when they watched I sat
next to my mum and dad and for everyone
who watches the opening season how did
the conversations go yeah
while they knew it was inevitable their
parents would probably see more than
they wanted to garhwa forbade his mom
from watching certain scenes Tanya
Reynolds on the other hand was forced to
get very upfront with her dad since he
was kind of in denial as to just how
explicit the series would be times it's
called sex education I'm just gonna
leave that there
when kidor William Sterling and Emma
Mackey were filming their romantic and
intimate scene every moment was planned
down to literal seconds
while performing such an explicit act in
front of a whole crew is bound to be
embarrassing to a certain extent
approaching the scene with a plan and as
if it were a dance made the whole ordeal
a bit more laid back for the actors this
was definitely a good thing considering
just how many scenes and takes they had
to do yeah yeah
when the series began before the actors
and crew even started filming any of the
intimate scenes they were all required
to take part in a full day intimacy
Workshop there the group shared their
own positive and negative experiences
with intimacy on set so intimacy
coordinator Eda O'Brien could help them
navigate how to approach the explicit
scenes they even used what O'Brien calls
sensual rhythms and looked at how
animals approached intimacy everything
from snails to gorillas and lions the
slugs have beautiful sets each actor
shared where they were comfortable being
touched during scenes so everyone could
respect each other's bodies and feelings
using these tools the actors felt
totally equipped and much safer when
filming what would normally be extremely
embarrassing and awkward scenes I think
she would be a platypus sex education
broke new ground when they were the
first show to use an intimacy director
including Ida O'Brien is the show's
intimacy coordinator was a gay Game
Changer and resulted in really positive
experiences for the actors who felt safe
and prepared to take on intimate scenes
while the intimacy coordinator was on
set and helping everyone prepare for the
spicier moments the first few days
getting to know everyone and Performing
such intimate scenes was still very
embarrassing
um that was awkward in ASA Butterfield's
childhood the birds and the bees talk
was often joked about Butterfield's
father never failed to embarrass him
when the family was watching a movie
whenever a spicier scene came on his
father or another family member would
jump in it was your favorite bit to this
day it still embarrasses the actor and
I'll get like a shop that's not these
performers definitely had their work cut
out for them the sex education team
manages to bring funny realistic and
embarrassing intimate scenes to life and
succeeds in telling the special story of
the teenagers at mordale which scene do
you think would have been most awkward
to film